Jeff Jarvis Oh Jeff Jeff used to be the
critic for a TV Guide in an instant
yesterday without any any media
appearances without any late night shows
without any of that you became number
one on Amazon you have the power my
leash
well thanks Jeff I'll tell you I and I
got to go out and promote this thing cuz
I'm so proud of it I just think people
are gonna love reading it they say a
little bit more but we're gonna get well
I told you yesterday what I what it
started out was was I started out
writing a book about my interviews
because I'm most proud of them I'm just
gonna put out kind of like a coffee
table book of the interviews and then I
said well let me write an intro and talk
about by process what I've been going
through lately what brought me to a new
style and what it's been like to go to
Sirius XM so that's like the intro then
I started writing about each of the
people I feature in the book then I
started a write about the interviews I
couldn't get so I made that into a chat
then I started cutting up interviews and
two little like snippets of things and I
started to write introductions to that
and then you know so the thing evolved
into this really nice read that I could
see people this summer reading and also
it's a book I'm just super super proud
of I think we ought to spend some time
trying to guess which was your absolute
favorite interview I wonder if you know
that Robin I bet you'd know one would
you be able to guess I don't think I'll
be able to guess but I want a hint like
is it a really famous person yes
[Music]
I'm not gonna tell you right or wrong
okay I mean eventually I will because
I'm and was it been our serious time or
it was during serious okay I think it
Madonna just keeps sticking in my head
I'm not gonna say fred was interview
McCartney we'll see I was like could it
be was pretty [ __ ] important
important but was it the best that I
thought it was really good in spite of
the fact ease of beetle he's a legend
you held your cool even told there was
interesting for what he revealed yes but
I'm gonna say I also thought Letterman
but I'm not sure I don't know Gary I
don't know if I want you getting why not
I want Terry to gasps Gary guess go
ahead I don't know because he's privy to
certain things that I was talking about
all right go ahead
I get that straight why'd you say people
seem to think that you're after your
first Billy Joel interview that just
yeah changed a bit interesting he was
way more bonded with Millie Joel that
first interview was pretty amazing I
don't want to say yeah because I feel
like that's something I can do is slow
review this like a striptease